um thanks for the introduction and
thanks for being here i know it's the
end of the day and
not very early in the week so i
appreciate that you're still here
um i'm going to talk about
multi-distribution learning problems
and
sort of these problems are related to a
range of applications from sort of
collaboration learning fairness to
federation and many other applications
but sort of where they all of these
applications start and the motivation
for all of this work starts is that
more and more in modern machine learning
we are working in learning paradigms
where the data that we are working with
is already spread across a bunch of
different sources either it's naturally
spread by you know the the way that it
was stored in the first place or is
generated by just completely
heterogeneously different groups of
people or
distributional processes
um and
what i really want to do is to actually
align all these
learning problems together
because
because in practice
the methods that work best for learning
require really this data and they have
to sort of bring this data together
so what are some challenges that this
kind of having more data and more spread
out data is really giving us
some of these challenges include the
fact that the ownership of the data is
now a lot more
spread out so the data is
spread across multiple sources
and
with the data being spread across
sources or being owned by different
agents
there's also different learning
guarantees that different agents might
want from their data
so that might mean that
the solutions that we're trying to
deploy in practice have to hold on
multiple different types of communities
or multiple different types of devices
or they have to be sort of robust to
whatever happens to the current
distributions that we are going to be
working with
and lastly
i also have to procure resources for
learning whether it's sample complexity
whether it's computation from the people
who have the data or from the
populations who have the data from the
people who are interested in learning
and now this procurement of the data
takes a more challenging perspective
because i have to align the incentives
of somebody for achieving good learning
guarantees with their incentive to not
want to
have a lot of cost producing those
resources that i need to rely on
so more data more stakeholders really
more challenges and these challenges
that we have to deal with that i want
you to remember across the
talk today is the ownership being spread
out
requiring sort of individualized and
heterogeneous type learning objectives
and then thinking about how to procure
resources from these multiple agents and
sources now why do we care i gave you
some examples of why this is happening
in modern machine learning but i think
it's important to look back in the past
few years especially thinking about
where these types of applications both
from really practice and also
theoretical foundation have been playing
a big role so thinking about learning
from multiple distributions essentially
what we are trying to enable is we are
trying to enable learning
processes that would benefit multiple
agents
and from collectively fewer resources
and sort of from practical applications
these data sharing and joint learning
some of you might have heard of them
aspirated learning collaborative
learning algorithms are starting to be
deployed across multiple devices
and across multiple also agencies
multiple hospitals medical research
institutes and they're
starting to become to play a very big
role in how we learn across multiple
data sources so we really need to
understand them
besides that they've been really behind
some major scientific discoveries that
couldn't have happened without sharing
data across multiple agencies this has
been especially the case for
medical research and especially for
genomic studies where the data is just
so spread out that without really
aligning the incentives of these
agencies and and bringing the data
across from each other and learning
something that works for everyone we
wouldn't have been able to actually make
these scientific discoveries so that's
kind of like practically speaking why
these matter
but since we are at simon's institute
and your theoretician most of your
theoreticians including myself
um they have also played a big role in
the foundational theory of several
fields in particular for multi-agent
collaboration welfare
perspectives on fairness and also
robustness
of learning
so that's what we're going to be talking
about so really the practical aspect of
this is that these algorithms are
already starting to be deployed
and what we want is to be able to get
this large-scale impact of them by
making sure that we can actually have
mass participations of these agents that
are willing to give us their data and we
are willing we are able to satisfy their
requirements and we need to essentially
be able to recruit and retain these
learning agents and distributions
so what are some of the fundamental
questions that we should be asking in
this and how is this tutorial going to
prepare us in asking and then hopefully
answering these questions
the first one is a very
standard thing that you need to answer
which is that fine i have a learning
algorithm how do i know it's a good
algorithm
what is the measure of success of a
learning algorithm
i can no longer talk about loss for one
distribution i might have many many
different distributions what is the
right way to think about
this loss when i have many different
tasks
and
maybe you want to think about if i were
to create some objective functions what
would be the objective function that i
should create so that it will be
meaningful when i'm dealing with
multiple agents
the second question is fine now i have
an objective function that maybe we all
agreed on it's a good objective function
for capturing
learning like a good measure of success
for learning across multiple
distributions then what do i have to do
well i have to figure out this is a
learning problem how many resources i
need to use or sufficient for me to be
able to actually meet those learning
guarantees as defined in q1
and here resources could be sample
complexity which is most of the focus of
today's talk but you could also think
about computational resources and other
types of resources maybe communication
and here what we really want to do is to
try to
rely on
try to rely on theory that's been
developed for typical learning problems
for single distribution learning
problems and really bring it to an area
that can now address multiple agents and
multiple distributions
and lastly
now that we know how many resources we
need how do we go about procuring these
resources typically in learning theory
this is just like talking about i just
need so many samples and i take it from
a distribution
but now i have to figure out who is
willing to give me those samples because
of how much you're receiving in return
from the algorithm the learning
algorithm is taking so many other people
in mind
so these are the three questions
and i want to just give you a
sense of what to expect from this
tutorial because
all three are important but we don't
have time to address all three and
enough depth
so to start for the first question i'm
actually not going to go in a lot of
depth in a lot of depth and what i'm
going to do is to give you one unifying
model one objective function
i'll give you some justification for
this but without going into too much
detail and i'll give you some pointers
for reading more about what other
objective functions have been studied
and are reasonable in the setting
part of the reason i don't want to go
into too much detail here is that in
fact i think the last talk also gave you
a perspective on the same question
so let's not redo all of that i think
that was a really valuable perspective
already
for the second question
that's where i actually do want to focus
quite a bit because what i want to do is
to give you a unifying perspective on
this multi-distribution learning
problems i keep saying
multi-distribution learning problems you
probably have no idea yet what they are
of course but i'm going to tell you how
they've captured recent progress in
machine learning from different
communities and my goal from this
tutorial is that i give you a unifying
view so that when you see these problems
again and it seems like in the past five
to ten years we keep seeing them you can
identify these problems and then you can
think about how to use technical tools
that i'm introducing today
for the purpose of actually dealing with
that kind of problem
so that's
for the second part of the tutorial
for the last part of the tutorial
i'm not going to go into too much depth
there instead of giving you a lot of
technical tools i actually want to have
a call to action here this is an area
that is not developed as much definitely
not as much as q1 and q2 but i'm going
to try to quantify some of the
trade-offs that's necessary to address
question three
highlight some of the technical
challenges and then i hope to see some
of you in the semester thinking about
some of these problems and chatting with
you guys
okay so that's what to expect from the
tutorial i'll go actually in order q1 q2
q3 uh with the amount of focus that i
already explained
before i continue are there any general
questions
okay
so the first question was how should we
measure the learning performance across
different tasks
so the typical thing that we are used to
doing in machine learning
is to think about average guarantees for
performance
um what that means is that i don't
really care where my data is i just put
it all together and what i want to do is
to say that on average over all my data
sources
i have five percent error something like
that
and this is a very reasonable way to
think about the learning problem when
i'm thinking about average performance
especially if i think about my data as
being somewhat arbitrarily partitioned
across different sources like if it was
a data center that someone arbitrarily
decided how to divide the data to k
different servers that would be a pretty
reasonable thing to think about
it's also generally good when the data
is very homogeneous across sources for
other reasons
now
when is this not good well
obviously we can come up with really bad
examples of this but it's usually when
the data is has some human and
organizational aspect to it
where the tasks or the distributions or
the groups or the populations are no
longer homogeneous so if i don't have
homogeneous groups it's really easy to
think about yes i have five percent
error on average but who is really
bearing that error is possible that one
of those groups is bearing 50
of um
of
of of the error and that group is like
not that insignificant maybe 10 of the
population
and this is again i feel like last talk
also talked about some of the challenges
here of thinking about going beyond
average performance
so
what is the issue here
the issue here is that actually i wanted
to first show this
i know i gave you something that
of course mathematically is very easy to
come up with why this thing can happen
but should we worry about this happening
in practice as well or not and i just
want to give you one graph here that
shows that you should absolutely worry
about this in practice the fact that
even in typical data
learning problems what we can see is
that the average performance and sort of
the worst case performance are really
far from each other and they require
different amounts of work from each
other so like if i'm thinking about
trying to get average accuracy of 70
in a very typical data set
what i would require is that for every
sort of agent to give me a lot of an
amount of data that's something like
about let's say 40 rounds or try to
optimize 40 rounds of iterations
but then
if i really want the worst case accuracy
to be 70 percent i need essentially
everybody to do twice as much work
so
what this is saying is that even in very
typical you know data science tasks
things that are being done on day-to-day
basis
where i didn't try to craft a population
that looked very different it just was
natural differences that i saw
we are seeing a lot of differences in
inaccuracy versus average accuracy so
this is absolutely something you should
be worrying about
now what are some of the challenges of
dealing with problems of this kind
is that beforehand
i don't really know which distributions
are harder to learn from but if i keep
talking about learning from a
distribution as a task these can have
very different types of difficulties i
don't know what populations are easier
what populations are harder
in fact the ease or difficulty
is very contextual like whether or not a
population is easier completely depends
on who are the other populations because
if there's a lot of similarity across
multiple populations well that is
naturally easier
um
so it's kind of a bad idea to approach
these problems thinking that i need to
have a prefix budget for how much
resources or how much samples or how
much computation i expect from every
distribution
really i need to actually allow the
tasks to speak to me about their own
difficulty and then figure out how i
need to actually procure resources how
much sample complexity or how much
computational complexity i need so these
are some of the challenges in this space
okay so what is multiple
multi-distribution learning problems
here i'm advocating for per-group type
guarantees again somewhat similar to
what you saw in the last talk
let's formalize this by thinking about k
populations populations are
distributions and are lingua today so i
have distributions d1 to dk you could
think about them as patients in a
hospital you could think about them as
data on different servers
what i want to learn is i want to learn
a function f
that is good for every population now
what does this mean it means that i have
some known loss function i've agreed
upon you know maybe this is
classification loss whatever whatever
loss it is somebody
told me what this loss is
i evaluate
every function or on every distribution
and what i want is that the worst case
loss which is the maximum over these
distributions is small and small is
shown here by an epsilon
so such a kind of guarantee would
essentially say that i'm trying to
uncover a universally good model and
universally is defined by being good on
every population
um sometimes this is just too much to
hope for especially if epsilon has to be
zero because
maybe there is no such a model that can
do well maybe
my first distribution and my second
distribution are exactly opposite of
each other so this is too much to ask
for
the right way to ask this question in
the more general setting is to say that
i want to do as best as possible so i'm
still evaluating or measuring the
success of my learning algorithm as its
loss
on the worst case distribution but then
i compare it to a benchmark that from
now on you're going to be calling off
which is the min max
type benchmark it's the best model
but then i took the worst case
distribution in my mind
and then i'm trying to match that plus
on epsilon
so this is kind of like this ops is the
best i could hope for if i were to
actually learn a model from the class
and this is more general it doesn't
necessarily mean that you uncover
something that was universally good but
it does have this type of flavor that
you did as best as you could have done
if you were really concerned about the
worst case behavior
any questions about the
you want to model that populations are
uh overlapping or not intersecting or it
doesn't matter
the great um
the great thing about this model is that
you do not need to make any additional
assumptions um in fact that's kind of
why i introduced the general model if we
were really sticking with this we needed
to make some assumption about
if they're overlapping or not or if they
overlap they don't disagree or not so
the good thing about this model is that
you don't need to make any additional
assumptions
that's a that's a good question so uh
what sid is saying is that a pessimistic
view of this is that
it doesn't have any perito optimality
involved in it you know i i could make
everybody very miserable um as miserable
as the worst group had to be and that's
absolutely true this objective does not
capture that
this goes to the question of how to
design these objectives there are
different objectives that do take that
into account
and there are also works that have
looked at the pareto optimality of these
things um i'll have some citations but i
don't have a lot i'll put them on slack
um
let me just say that if i were to kind
of like change this objective so that
sid would be happier
um i would change this max right so one
way to think about this is that it's an
l infinity type
you know norm
l1 would have been the average and you
could just put some other norm there and
those are the very
well studied in fact
kind of these cardinal welfare utility
type questions but there are even
objectives that don't fall in that
category and they're also interesting
but for today we're going to stick to
this min max because it's very robust
and i want to also highlight the
technical tools that really show
themselves like show their power in the
setting best yes
some of the motivating applications that
you mentioned
i would imagine that you can have an f
which is for each group like an f5
maybe for others this is the right
combination
yeah so that's also a good question um
in fact that will come back again in the
talk the fact that i intentionally put
the same f here
the same f here
um
so it's true
there are applications where you can put
f i
uh on the left hand side and it turns
out to be not at least if you don't care
about the third part of the talk which
is about incentives it doesn't really
matter like everything i tell you as
long as you're really trying to do this
on the right hand side you're not making
it much easier or much harder for
yourself to allow people to get
different uh functions or not
so that's about the strength of the
tools that i'm going to be talking about
uh i want to say that while for some
applications that is definitely true
almost for every application i mentioned
today you don't want to give a different
fi and i will come back
i think in the next slide about some of
these applications and there i'll
motivate it again why
why it's actually important to have the
same as
other questions
okay so so this is the setting we're
gonna come back to it i haven't really
told you what this losses i it's very
general
in fact
in this generality it includes um many
things in it but
just not to lose sight of the questions
especially the ones that are inspiring
our technical discussion today what you
are really trying to do is to go from
one learning one distribution to
learning multiple distributions so this
would have been the
single distribution learning problem
like a single d
unknown and i would have needed to make
this type of a
guarantee and the multi-distribution
just has that max of i in
in front of the loss
and what we really want is to really
understand this
but there has been decades of work on
the left hand side so what i want to do
is to show that
that not necessarily in a reduction way
but the insights the algorithms the
techniques that we've developed here
very naturally can extend to here so
instead of solving the right hand side
from scratch i actually want to use that
okay now
why is this a unifying perspective
well
um
actually before i tell you why this is
very unifying
let me tell you what losses we are going
to be working with the losses for this
talk are losses that um decompose nicely
over the distribution what does it mean
it means that they're actually relate to
an expectation of some point wise loss
what's a good example of this you can
think about this as binary
classification where there is a loss
that says i evaluate f on an x and then
if it has an error then i take the
average error okay
um
in general you just want that loss the
point wise loss to be like um
finite and range it doesn't really
matter
but
in fact to emphasize this i'm going to
use this formulation where d is a
subscript
the reason i wanted to say this this way
is that there are losses that in fact
the same picture that i'm talking about
is still something we want to do but
they don't fall in this expectation and
one of them was the
the calibration loss essentially that we
were talking about in the previous talk
it is not something that you can just
write as an expectation because it takes
into account the prediction of your own
classifier
but it's something you could have
written it this way and it has some
other nice properties it just doesn't
fall exactly under what you're going to
be discussing okay so for the rest of
the talk just have in mind a loss that
has this type of expectation in general
it could have been just convex loss or
many other ones
now in this formulation i promise to
tell you that why this is a unifying
perspective it's important to really try
to understand it so that we can
recognize this type of problems it's
because in the span of maybe two to
three years at least three separate
communities um came up with the same
problem as one of the important problems
of their field
and uh tried to address this problem and
these communities have actually grown
almost
separately from each other
so from the more theory
oriented community this was something
that we actually called collaborative
learning in 2017 part of the reason we
called up called it collaborative
learning is that the eye for us was
representing like a distribution that
was owned by an agent and then we wanted
to really think about agents willingness
to collaborate and to help each other to
learn
this is a setting that you sometimes can
give different fis but sometimes you
actually want to give the same f it kind
of depends on what you mean by
collaboration
now there's a separate community this
was more from the federated and then
later on systems community that um named
this agnostic fair federated learning i
introduced the fair because most people
think about it as fair federated
learning
and uh in this case
kind of the the eyes represent client
distributions that we were thinking
about and their main purpose was to
provide these fairness goals and
implications the one that says no
population is
um is to to worse off
and then from third community which is
now mostly neural networks and natural
language processing
but it actually has some of its root in
theory as well it's known as group
distribution robust optimization
and this setting focuses on optimize
optimization and not learning
what that means is that it's not really
about sample complexity it's more about
you know designing algorithms that can
do this they don't care about
generalization quite as much it's more
of a sort of an optimization and
algorithm design setting
again they're inspired by fairness but
also robustness so sometimes for them
the eyes don't represent actual
populations but they represent
hypothetical situations where my
distribution could have shifted and i
want to sort of be able to perform well
in any of these weird shifts that could
have happened okay so these are at least
three different communities i'm saying
at least three and at least three lines
of work because
essentially this problem has popped up
over at least independently over at
least something like five to ten papers
and each within its own sort of
technical tools and within within its
own community so i think it's kind of
important to like figure out the
similarities so we don't necessarily put
a lot of effort in reinventing the
wheels but to actually have a unifying
perspective on these
so
as promised
for fairness and for robustness it's
actually quite important to give the
same f
for robustness that's the definition you
want the same model to do well for
fairness there are also some legal
reasons for why usually you want to have
the same f
from technical perspective it doesn't
really matter
beyond this talk um
i already said a little bit uh to sid
for example um which is that how would
you go about you know like other
important questions here um so
in general like these have been studied
and
similar models have been studied in
terms of both economic and welfare
perspective on min-max objectives
so there is an axiomatic and
non-automatic approaches to just general
cardinal welfare and then some
perspective of learning
i
put some papers on slack i forgot to
include here there's also
from accuracy furnace tradeoffs for
example these perito optimal curves
that's actually a work by annie liang
who is uh
and collaborators who is uh this
semester's participant as well so
like i encourage you to talk with her as
well
so there's definitely more work um that
kind of justifies why you want to think
about these problems but that's not
going to be the focus of my talk today
okay so this is as much as i wanted to
talk about question one
which was how do i set up essentially
the model and if there are any questions
about the setup or the justification
this is a good time to ask because the
next thing we're gonna do is to take
this objective at its face value and try
to learn it so are there any questions
[Music]
let me go back to just say
how what kind of excess
we are going to have maybe i should just
go here
so
then i whenever essentially in this talk
i talk about unknown distributions you
want to decay i give you a sample oracle
access to it what that means is that you
cannot go to one person and identify
which group they're in because they
could have been part of many groups
you cannot in fact
you do not even have that kind of access
to data
the type of access you do have to data
is you identify which distribution and
how many samples you want to take from
it so it's very similar to kind of
traditional like theory of machine
learning pack learning style
for those of you who are not familiar
with it do not worry i will come back to
that and give you a little bit just so
that you don't feel like you don't know
what i'm talking about okay
that's one other question so you were
saying with the f5 technically it's
going to be uh the same methodology and
stuff so i just wanted to confirm the
formulas it's on the on the left hand
side you'll have f5 on the right hand
side is it going to be 1 8 star or it's
going to be like yeah yeah it has to be
one the same h star
yeah you're still kind of evaluating
yourself with that um for different
reasons if you just put different h
stars then they're really independent
problems then you should yeah there's no
nothing that binds them together
that's a good question so especially the
motivation i like it a lot here
which is about realizability so a lot of
times what we have is that we have
this same concept but different sort of
marginal distribution okay what does
that mean it means that a cat is a cat
doesn't matter you know which country
they live in but the pictures of cats
posted from i don't know the us and iran
probably are very different right so
that's what that means is that there
would have been an f h star that would
have explained what a cat looks like but
maybe the classifier that would have
worked really well on the american
pictures wouldn't have worked as well on
the arena picture so that would be one
example of this but similarly here like
they come back again with sort of the
same type of motivations
yes
good okay it does strictly make the
problem easier i guess what i meant is
that
from the resource asymptotic
resources that we need to solve this
problem it doesn't make it easier
and that is partly because of the way
that we have pretty powerful methods
um
let me when i get to that point
point out um
why it's okay
um
they're essentially asymptotically
speaking
there's not that much difference between
working with the same function like
giving the same function versus giving
different functions
maybe okay let me maybe say a few words
here for those of you who already are
familiar with
learning theory
if i wanted to give different functions
sometimes if i had learned those
functions in a good way
i could actually use their majority vote
or some other combinations of them
so that that combination would work
across everything
so it's similar ideas that says that
you sort of can always
do this
or more or less do this
so that learning the same function
but not necessarily coming from the
class is as good as having learned
or sorry it's no not much more difficult
as having learned individual functions
that's all i want to say right now
because
um
it is a more advanced question and a
more advanced answer but i'll come back
to that again if
there i'm sure there's still like
questions about this but let me come
back to that
other questions
okay
cool
so
let's go to
the second question that we want to ask
and so
we took this objective value this per
group type guarantees we want them now
the question is how can we get them
how can we get them from few resources
in other words we are really going to
build a theory of either computational
complexity or sample complexity for this
talk essentially i'm going to be talking
about sample complexity all the
interesting questions are there for
computation as well
so really the type of resource i'm
thinking about is information
information comes in the form of sample
so again i fix it i say i there's this
unknown distribution i take a few
samples from it i don't want to take too
many
and we're going to focus on the number
of samples and
most of what i say has some implication
about computation but i won't go into
that so again this is the problem i want
to solve now note that the loss is a the
special kind of loss of expected loss so
this has a meaning which is about the
true loss of a classifier on a on a on a
distribution let's even think about it
as binary classification
and i want to really talk about how many
resources i need about this problem
for the sake of comparison i actually
want to be able to compare to single
distribution
and i want to understand like is this
easier or harder than you know solving k
of these single distribution problems is
this significantly easier or
significantly harder that type of
comparison kind of tells me whether this
formulation is actually a nice
formulation for also bringing together
especially for collaborative
applications that we're thinking about
if it gives me something more than sort
of ignoring
everything and solving the problems
separately
so here i want to go back to basics
for learning a single distribution
um because
we come from very different backgrounds
what i want to do
is to spend
a slide talking about if you've never
seen sort of the standard pac offline
learnability
how would you think about that problem
and why it's not that hard and sort of
we we don't keep coming back to this but
i think it's still a nice exercise to
have in mind just so that we have our
expectation of sample complexity right
so if you know if you've taken a course
in learning theory this is going to be
probably a repeat for you
but all i want to do is to recall that
if i had a single distribution
i
want to use samples from that
distribution and learn a hypothesis that
has near optimal error
and what i'm going to do is a very
natural algorithm it's called empirical
risk minimization or erm you've probably
heard about it and what it does is it
just takes a number of samples
sufficiently large number of samples
and then what it does is that it takes
the classifier or the hypothesis that
looked the best on that sample case so
it's loss or it's
error it was the least possible on that
set
so
then what do i really need to say if i
want the outcome of this erm which was
computed on a sample set to actually
have some meaningful
performance on the distribution
i have to say that i took
large enough number of like sufficiently
large
sample set
so that essentially every
uh function's error
true error the error is expected around
the distribution was really well
approximated on the sample set
in fact if i just say that every
function was well approximated
to the degree like epsilon over 2
then whatever the erm gives me
can be at most epsilon worse than the
optimal function
so this is really now about an
estimation
and whether or not i can estimate a lot
of functions from the same set of data
so how do we do this
this is really when statistics comes in
let's make it simple let's assume that i
had a finite set of hypothesis or find a
set of classifiers
so all i have to now use are two tools
concentration bounds and union bound
what does that mean it just means that
at the end of the day i want to say that
the probability
that the
empirical loss this is evaluated in the
sample sentence
versus the true loss evaluated on the
distribution are far from each other is
low i want this bad event
to be a very low probability bad event
and note that this bad event has to hold
for all functions within a finite set of
function classes
so if i took just a single one of these
then
i just have this huffling bound that
tells me how quickly
something from samples converges to its
mean
so this is the huffling bound for any
fixed classifier
now because i want this to hold for
every classifier all i have to do is to
take the union bound over the number of
these
classif classifiers so this is really a
simple way to think about this union
bound often bound and i want this to be
arbitrarily small maybe a very tiny
constant and that tells me what the
sample complexity would be
now the reason i'm doing this is that
this is an offline goal of thinking
about problems and so far i feel like
this week we've talked a lot about
online way of thinking about problems
but this is even simpler than online
now what would have happened if the
function class was not finite
well there's a concept called vc
dimension
good news is that we don't need to know
what it means it just all we need to
know is that it essentially controls
something that is very similar to the
size of hypothesis classes it
essentially controls the effective size
of the hypothesis
so instead of h size of h i just replace
this with something that is exponential
in vc dimension it doesn't really matter
at the end of the day what i get out of
this is that especially for the finite
case i want this to be very small
m which is my number of samples has to
be like one over epsilon squared
log of h
so that is
um the type of sample complexity bounds
that we think about okay when you do
have vc dimension bounds this is what it
looks like
now
again since we've seen regret more than
error so far
they translate to each other really
nicely like another way to think about
this is that the average regret which
would have been that playing the role of
epsilon
would have been square root of vc or
log h divided by t
so that's just kind of translating to if
you've seen regret this is essentially
doing the same thing but it's not even
adversarial something just gave you
samples from the same distribution
so this is for learning a single
distribution are there any questions
about this
this is just a mathematical exercise
telling us how simple it is to learn
from a single distribution
okay
so
let's come back
now that we know how we can learn from a
single distribution what a sample
complexity is i want to do another
thought exercise which is that
what can i actually hope for in terms of
sample complexity of now k different
tasks okay and in particular k different
tasks the way we discuss them not in
isolation necessarily the way we discuss
them
and i want you to know
if you had to bet what would you bet
so
what is the range here i have the sample
complexity of a single distribution
single task what we saw in the previous
style
i have k times the same sample
complexity asymptotically okay i
i'm allergic to constants so
um asymptotically speaking k times the
same amount okay
now what do you think
is going to require for solving this
problem
should i
expect the sample complexity to be here
even more than k
should i expect it to be between
one distribution and k
and i mean okay we all know it's not
going to be there okay
so i guess wouldn't the answer depend on
whether you can draw samples from each
of the distributions or
just one
you have access to any distribution you
want to draw from so the d1 to dk
you can choose a distribution like you
said i want a sample from d3 and then
you take as many samples as you want
okay think about the think about like
populations being like different cities
i go to a city and i decide that i'm
going to boston and then i take iid from
boston i decided to go to san francisco
so that is important you should be able
to you should have sample access to nabi
okay
now with that in mind if you had to bet
who was this
ah okay you're fixing eight and then
you're sending k to infinity after
fixing it
i think that's a good way to think about
it but i do want to like let's just let
this be a conversation so if if i wasn't
doing that is there something
that uh
that you want to say
i mean it could be that h is very
complex but then i will let k be even
large compared to the big c dimension of
h and then right
but maybe that's not realistic
okay
right so so that's true if k is much
bigger than vc dimensional much smaller
than bc dimension these fall in two
different regimes
in particular
if k is much smaller than bc dimension
what can happen
is that um
let's say k is like three something like
that
then i can actually create three
isolated learning problems that have
nothing to do with each other and at
that point i'm much closer to being here
right but because we are thinking about
asymptotics in k let's allow yourself to
play with k
as it goes from zero to infinity
so what happens there
sounds very possible
so that's that's a very good question
that's a very good answer
um
there are two forces here
that
one should make you a little bit
concerned
to make you feel like maybe this is
going to take more than k distributions
and then there are some forces that tell
you actually no this is going to take
less than k i feel like both of you have
talked about why
it could take less than k samples and
it's kind of like saying that
yeah like learning problems can be
related to each other
and sort of
once they're related to each other i
shouldn't go above k i should be here
and in particular maybe log k
but forget about log or square root or
whatever
why don't you think like
should you worry about it being greater
than k or is there any force at least
that concerns you to start with
it's just like yesterday 100
here's a sample complex of learning the
worst case distribution like the worst
case of the
k times not but you are saying that
given d1 and dk the sample complexity of
learning d1 and some components are
learning d2 yes um
that's a very good point let me clarify
what i'm doing
um
when i say sample complexity of learning
one distribution i mean worst case
distribution i don't mean
i don't mean this to be as sum of the
sample complexity of d1 to dk in fact
you cannot get those results as easily
um
yeah are you allowed to violate like are
you allowed to choose f from outside
edge
then should be bounded by
should be bounded by k okay
so let me just say that why
while you guys are very smart and you
definitely know this
why a lot of people feel queasy when
they see this okay it's because there
are two forces and one is the one that
all of you identified
but i don't want to lose sight of the
other one because
a lot of the communities that i
mentioned actually work in this regime
and their reasons for it
so what are these two forces so the
first force is the one that you identify
the fact that distributions could relate
to each other and in fact if i keep the
function class the same and i increase
the number of distributions i just
cannot make too many independent
problems
in some way if i want my learning
problems to be really far from each
other very different
i'm making this opt to be really bad too
and then because opt is really bad it's
not that hard to learn something that's
trivially bad
or they have to be very related to each
other in which case it really helps to
sample from one and learn about the
other so that's the force that we all
identify with and that's really nice
the second one is the thing that does
worry people and i
i think it's good to think about it
which is that
i need to give this give the same f okay
i told daniel not to worry about it but
you know if you didn't know that you
shouldn't worry about it then you would
have worried about it and you would have
thought that
i need to coordinate
so even if individually like i just told
people to go learn a function for their
own distribution and come together
there's no guarantee that i don't need
any additional samples to actually learn
a function that would agree
so this coordination should be something
that is highly non-trivial
and
should sort of it's usually a source of
concern
and that's why a lot of communities work
in this space because they
kind of worry about the fact that
um
that this kind of they mostly are after
the fact of saying that coordination is
not a big problem
of each okay
what you're asking is can i find a
single number which is
close to all the means yeah i think for
it's important it's kind of nice to
think about what f is representing here
and i think it's it's important here
because you don't see that happening
with the mean estimation but it happens
here
when i fix the function complexity class
and i increase the number of
distributions i cannot have independent
arms or independent distributions that
much just to respond to i don't think
you're claiming that we get equally good
by selecting one f but we are satisfying
the guarantee by somebody satisfying
that's true
that's true yeah so so okay so i i'm not
trying to trick you i just expected that
at least half of you to worry about this
and that's why i put it on the slide but
you guys are so smart so you didn't
worry about it but if you had to worry
about it what i would tell you to like
tell you to calm down
is
this is about combining different
functions which looks very similar like
combining different experts
and we'll see why they're similar enough
and also to make you again really not to
worry about this i would say that well
just think about the setting where there
is no obvious misalignment between these
you know do the thought exercise when i
was in the realizable setting now there
is still coordination but like it's kind
of like saying that i have k different
problems one of them is the hardest and
i just need to really identify which one
is the hardest
so
you didn't worry about this but if you
had to worry about this hopefully now
you're very calm
okay
so you're right in the sense that
what we will show is something of the
form lock k
i will say that it's off the form log k
because sometimes it's better than us
and sometimes it's lock k um
and that kind of depends whether the
function class is finite or not finite
it's really because there is something
else that is characterizing this log k
which i don't want to go into for today
just i'm purely guessing but is it like
p if it's alphy norm
is it p times or is it no it's actually
a little bit it's a different story a
little bit
um it is about
it is about how fast you can like use a
dual space
but i don't think it's just p
i'll give you the tools and then you can
just apply to anything
okay um okay since i did say this um to
actually get this type of regime we'll
see that it's really important to use a
distribution a very specific way
and the communities that haven't used
the distribution in those specific way
especially like the line of work that
comes from federated learning and
robustness
they
fall in this category and i will sort of
tell you one reason they fall in this
category in the next slide
so the reason here is that
at a high level to actually learn
optimally
you need to coordinate across different
distributions you need to get them to
interact like especially if it was like
a collaborative thing you need to do
this in a very adaptive way
what does lack of interactions look like
well it looks like in setting if i
decided on the number of samples
learning rates update frequencies all of
these in a non-interactive way
and what the problem with that type of
approach is that it sort of ignores the
varying the fact that distributions have
different difficulties
because the only way that you can catch
up with the fact that distributions have
different difficulties is if you try to
learn a little bit and then see like
when where you're not doing super well
with respect to other distributions
um
so
here really
to benefit from
from this type of
cross-learning that the ones that we
know that bring down the sample
complexity from of k
then what you need to do is to really
allow these distributions to interact
with each other
what is an example of this type of
interaction
is that the decisions we make about
distribution i whether about what
predictor you know we are more likely to
learn or how much samples we are taking
from it what is you know update
frequencies all the things that you
might think about in a learning
algorithm
they have to depend on how well di has
done so far
compared to the rest of the
distributions okay so it's not just
about even its own behavior it's about
its own behavior compared with the rest
of the agents and that comparison is the
important thing
so the degree that if you don't do this
if you are even adaptive but not in this
way kind of what you can get is that
there's no way you can go below this ofk
time is learning as simple as a single
class okay so this adaptivity is
actually an important aspect of thinking
about sample complexity
recently i've been calling it in my head
as on-demand learning in terms of
thinking about it as i decide where i
need to do more and then i do more there
so that's kind of what i've been
thinking about it but sort of the
takeaway here is that without an
interactive protocol these
multi-distribution learning especially
if you want to think about as
collaboration
they're essentially as ineffective
as not at all allowing the distributions
to
collapse to work together at all okay so
this adaptivity
and interaction is the key
to getting better than solving k
separate learning problems independently
okay
so
now that we know we need to do
interactions adaptivity and coordination
um
how do we go about them
and luckily we are in a week that we
have learned so much about online
learning and online processes because
interaction coordination adaptivity
there are all things that are get that
gets enabled by online algorithms
just the way that we think about online
algorithms has this kind of an adaptive
thing that the next thing we do depends
on how well previous options have worked
out
so that has that activity back in it
but i don't want to just give you one
other lecture about no regret learning
what i want to do here is
to go back to the unifying perspective
that actually unifies no regret learning
and these problems
and talk more about that and how you
would sort of fundamentally try to solve
this problem optimally
and to do that i want to go back to a
min max optimization perspective or min
max formulation of games
what is min max min max is one way to
think about having two agents one is
trying to minimize some loss the other
is trying to maximize the other loss and
that this is this shared loss that they
have
and we know a lot of
we know we know a lot about how to
compute these things
in particular
what this function f is
is an approximate min max equilibrium
why it's because
in the worst case like it's a function
we commit to
that in the worst case over the
maximizing agent we are only epsilon off
from the this uh opt and this is
something called value of thickness
okay
now again
this is actually something that
throughout this week we've come so close
to directly addressing but none of the
talks so far directly address min max
games and no regret learning so i'm
going to take a second detour
to talk a little bit about them just
again enough to understand the
connection between them and no regret
learning even though
some of the talks we had came very close
to explicitly stating them
so what is the relationship between min
max and james equilibria and regret
well the min max game especially like
let's establish some
formulation here we have a game it's two
players whenever player one plays
something player two plays play one
plays x and player two plays y
then both of them get them gets
utilities u1 and u2
min max game is one where the utility of
the one of them is minus the utility of
the other one okay
and in fact we are going to just talk
about losses as minus the utility of one
of them and the other guys the minus of
that loss
now from the game carry perspective min
max maximum all these solution concepts
are really nicely equivalent in these
types of games
essentially we think about mixed
strategies where people each agent picks
um distribution over either rows or
columns
and then
what they get is the expected loss here
shown by capital l of p and q p and q
are distributions capital l is the
expected loss
and min max versus max man essentially
says which player goes first and commits
to a strategy and the nice thing about
these games kind of like foundation of
um game theory in a sense is that it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter who
goes first because min max and max min
are the same
under some mild assumption one way to
think about it is that if x and y are
finite which actually translate to what
um subset of what you're working on
so
while the minmax theorem has improved
um
many many many decades ago
uh there was a really beautiful uh
proof of it through normal grad learning
only three decades ago
and uh that one i'm not going to give
but i'm going to tell you what it relies
on essentially it relies on thinking
about online learnability
as a way of dealing with min max because
they're both about interactions with an
adversary okay like online address or
not stochastic online adversarial
learning
and min max and one way to think about
this is that i take my two players
one of them i asked them to play a no
regret algorithm
the other one it doesn't really matter
as much they could best respond if they
want to the current thing that they see
or they can also use an organ algorithm
if they wish
so what does this look like the let's
say that the maximizing player is the
one that is playing best response so it
takes a distribution given by player one
so that's pt
and it's trying to maximize it and it
just uses qt that maximizes this loss
okay
what does player one do player one is
choosing pt in a way that compared to
the
best p at the end of time it doesn't
have regret
both of these we know how to do this is
just take any online algorithm this is
best response or do another online
algorithm
and the nice thing about this is that
the pair of the strategies that are the
average of what people have played
is an approximate min max
strategy
okay
that's all about the detour i wanted to
take
just to spell out the relationship
between regret and minmax because i now
want to talk about one way of solving
the problem i have through no regrets
algorithms
it's not
the approach i'll give you is not the
optimal way to do it but then i'll tell
you the optimal way without going
through too much details
okay
so how do i do this i want to think
about again
multi-distribution learning as game
solving
i'm going to reimagine
this problem as a game and this was the
game i wrote
and again to repeat all i care about is
to find an approximate min max
equilibrium
and
from the detour what i learned is that
what's sufficient to do to get an
approximate min max is to average that
ps and the queues that each player
played when one of them was a no regret
person
and the other one was the best responder
the thing is that here i'm switching the
road slightly the minimizing player
is uh
is this guy it's the h star
and i'm asking him to actually
uh
best respond and
the maximizing player is this guy who's
choosing the worst distribution and i'm
going to ask him to give me another
regret algorithm or to use an organ
algorithm
now
i'm going to have a no regard algorithm
and if i can have a no regret versus
best response let's just forget about
this game doesn't matter what it is if i
can get no regret plus best response i
can use the detour and i'm done
here there is an issue which is that
while i have a game
that game is not really defined and well
that game is not known to me
in the sense that the game loss function
itself is unknown
so if i want to actually get either of
these to work then no regret verse and
best response what i have to do is
essentially to do it with what i do not
know it again
but it's okay
i don't know the game but i can estimate
it hopefully whenever i want again from
samples
so this is where sample complexity
and
how good your no regret and your best
response algorithms have to be come
together
sort of the worse your regret the longer
you have to play this game
and presumably at every time you're
playing this game you need to estimate a
loss function which needs more and more
samples
okay
of course the better your regret
algorithm or the better your best
response is possible that it needs to be
really accurate so it needs very
accurate information here which means
that maybe in the first place it needed
just too many samples
but this is the connection between the
two
um so here is the promised good but not
optimal approach um this is the one that
you're using a norrican algorithm versus
the best response agent let's spell it
out what you mean so i said that the
minimizing player is going to be the
best responding agent
what that means is that
the let's let's look over what the
maximizing player did the maximizing
player chooses one of the distributions
from you know a mixture of them so
essentially the maximizing player has
given
me
alpha 1 to alpha k
this is just a convex combination that's
his strategy
in a way what the minimizing player
wants to do
is to really just find
a function that minimizes error for this
pt
it doesn't know how to do it without
doing erm so it's just going to take a
number of samples i'm just going to run
your
now what is the maximizing player is
going to do this is our no regret type
agent
so what he has to do is to maintain a
distribution over the k sorry
over the k distributions these are
weights these are the alpha i that i
talked about and if you recall from
earlier in the week how did we actually
maintain these weights something like
multiplicative weight hedge even
gradient descent
all what they were doing was that they
would sort of evaluate how well you were
doing on a specific arm each
distribution is now an arm and then they
would increase or decrease the weight or
the focus based on how well he's done
so what this maxwell has to do in order
to
come up with these weights is to of
course have a proxy of how poorly that
distribution has been treated so far
which again we need to do it from some
samples
so this is exactly where the samples are
coming in and this is also exactly where
the interactivity is coming in because
the next time around i take samples
depends on how well that distribution
was doing because that's defined by my
alphas
in fact another another way to think
about it is that the norwegian algorithm
is literally telling me how to procure
the resources that i wanted
because alpha i fraction of the
resources i'm taking per round is coming
from distribution di that's kind of the
meaning of having this convex
combination and trying to learn
something for that complex combination
okay
so is the algorithm clear
what i'm going to do is to tell you why
this algorithm works
and i'm going to do it by actually
making it a little bit simpler on myself
i'm going to make this assumption which
is that
um
this the min max that opt is zero just
because it makes things easier and it
doesn't really actually
technically is not introducing
too much of a challenge for what i'm
doing
okay
so let's let's do this
okay so let me write something that i
did not write so
so min player
is the best response player takes the pt
that was sum of alpha i t
d i
and then what i want from this player is
to say that whatever it learned like
let's say it was h of t
on p
defined at time t
is at most sum epsilon prime and this is
going to be like i don't know epsilon
over 10.
okay
that's the best response
um what i want my maximizing player to
do
is it's going to decide these alpha it's
i'm not going to write the no regret
algorithm it is an oracle algorithm if i
if i knew exactly how to evaluate losses
use hedge use whatever you want
but let's say that
it has to be based on
this l of the i
of
previous
previous like hypotheses
um like
let's say the last step
and since i don't know this
what i want to say is that the max
player took enough samples so the
estimate that it's using
versus
the true
value
would have also been like atmos and
epsilon prime
okay so these are the places where the
samples are coming in
i'm not going to go into the detail of
why it's okay to be a little bit off
within your weights it really doesn't
matter
um so let's assume that this epsilon
prime for this case was at least here
like this guy was really no regret in
reality it's just no regret plus another
epsilon prime which doesn't matter
okay now
what i'm going to use is that since i
use
hedge or whatever you want
the regret of it especially thinking
about average regret
is something like
log of k
times t
over t
why log k because this is the number of
actions for the second player
for the maximizing guy because he's
choosing one of the distributions so
that's where this is locked
okay now how is this all coming together
well
what
happens here
this is very similar to min max theorem
even though i didn't prove it for you
is that let's see what the maximizing
guy guarantees
so because he was a no regret person
then it's
with respect to the the max of ik this
is this is the benchmark okay
i'm writing the average utility that it
was going to have
[Applause]
okay
um
good okay so
okay so
what is this person what what is the
type of guarantees that this guy can
give
remember hts are defined by the first
player but the second player is no
regret with respect to so that would
have been its benchmark this is it's
like regret over t
and the actual utility that it got or
the actual loss that it gave it was
trying to maximize it is going to be the
average loss so far which is the loss
of h t
on p t
p t was the
the mixture that i defined based on
alphas okay
now
what did my best responding person
guarantee to me that at every time this
is at most epsilon prime
so this is at most epsilon right
okay
and actually the regret
also the way i defined it you know if i
think about let's say that
another way to think about this is that
run this algorithm for t equal 1 over
epsilon square
log k
epsilon prime squared doesn't matter
then this regret has already shrunk
to epsilon prime as well
okay
so what is this giving me now it gives
me the fact that um
if
i think about a randomize um learning
you know a randomized classifier let's
say that i call this a randomized
classifier what it really is is that it
draws a classifier from uniform
distribution
over the things i have learned
okay so these are the things that the
player number one has learned then what
is the expected error because this is
random expected over the randomization
of this classifier
it's just really this is going to be
loss of any
evaluated on any bi
this ht
is literally going to be the average
over the distributions
of sorry i would wear the classifiers of
h t
okay
now
at the end of the day i'm taking a max i
and this
is what
i have here
which is essentially 2 epsilon prime
okay
that's the type of guarantee that i
wanted to get
and the fact that i could be no regret
and best responding from samples
gave me that guarantee
okay now what's the sample complexity i
didn't tell you anything about sample
complexity
when it comes to samples
now where am i using my samples here
and here
and i'm using them too many times so
it's something like every time step
i'm using one
learning task worth of problems which by
the way was something like we see well
let me just block
and also i'm using something like enough
to to start to estimate a single
function which is another like 1 over
epsilon square
so this is
a good enough approach to give me
something like 1 over epsilon to the 4
log
k
log f that's not what i promised you
because the epsilon dependence is
definitely much worse than it should be
but it's nevertheless an approach that
can get the log k for you
okay
so this is just a simple approach not
optimal but a high level idea about how
you will solve this type of problem
okay
now with this in mind any questions
about it
with this in mind how would you actually
think about the optimal way of doing
this
well there were several things that were
baseball then
no regret was wasteful
too many samples two accurate estimates
all of it was kind of wasteful
and the sort of unifying way to again
think about this is that i'm trying to
solve a game that's stochastic game
and there are tools for this so in fact
sort of the tools that are known for
this are like one of them is stochastic
mirror prox algorithm i'm not gonna tell
you what it is but you can look it up
it's very good at solving games um and
the main idea is that it is not in our
red versus best responses so two no
regret algorithms that are sort of
intertwined with each other and they
sort of work well with each other
and uh
it's known to get really good bounds
generally for games
now what is not sufficient what's not
what doesn't necessarily come with
stochastic process is that sarcastic
mirror procs just assumes that it has
access to this kind of like noisy
estimates of something that noise is not
something that stochastic mirror
products itself controls it just comes
from a
stochastic gradient
um but what we can here do is we can
actually control how accurate of an
estimate we want at any given time for
any given function
so if you combine these ideas which this
the second type is closer to something
like adaptive sampling methods or just
kind of more carefully choosing when you
want information when you really um
cannot get away without accurate
information if you put these together
you can design optimal algorithms and
once you do that you get this type of a
guarantee
okay
this comes from two different works
um
the one that is for this kind of the
agnostic and the one i told you there
the smart way of doing that for
realizability was actually an older work
but it's really nice thinking about
mirror procs and doing this optimally
for
in the agnostic way is a work that's
much more recent and eric zhao is a
co-author is a student of mine who's
worked on this you should definitely
talk with him ask all the hard questions
from her so
so this is um this is kind of like the
approach that you can use to optimize
all these
okay
i'm going much slower than i thought
okay
so the takeaway
there are a couple of things i want you
to have from this conversation one is
that this was a unifying perspective if
you again see this type of a min max
which you inevitably are going to see
just thinking about generalizing from
the recent history at least um then it's
good to think about the tools that are
in your tool set and you can use them
but also that thinking about online
learning
so far it's been mostly used in terms of
thinking about oh adversarial behavior
here we're really using adversarial
behavior to actually design a nice
medium for collaboration and interaction
beyond adversarialness so i think this
is something good to think about as when
you can control both ends how it helps
you with environment design
okay
so the last bit which i poorly timed
myself
is going to be about a slightly
different type of consideration
and especially thinking about the fact
that minority algorithm was essentially
telling me how to procure my resources
who to sample from sometimes these
samples are quite expensive if i go to a
population and ask for more samples it's
not clear if they want to give me that
some of the expensive you know samples
come from physical domains um testing
lead pipes you know you have to actually
dig someone's backyard to like test
their pipes nobody wants to be the house
that has to do it unless they really
have to do it
um medical um
settings um it's quite expensive to do
testing so in all of these kind of more
physical related domains testing
sampling is very expensive
and people are happy to do it if they
can see an obvious benefit to themselves
but if it's not obvious that that
benefit is to themselves or not to
somebody else maybe they don't want to
do it
so if you're really going to be thinking
about collaboration or
multi-distribution learning what we need
to also understand is that how does it
benefit all users not just in terms of
the accuracy but also in terms of
accuracy
and information sort of um trade-off
so the third question is was that you
know how should we procure resources and
in a way this is a call to action for
going forward through towards a theory
for multi-agent sample complexity that
has incentives baked into it
so what are some reasonable share of
data let me tell you what our
unreasonable share of data because i
think that's much easier to think about
so we don't want to have this
unreasonable burden one example of an
unreasonable burden is that if i ask a
distribution to give me more data then
it would have been absolutely necessary
for that distribution to learn by
himself okay
that is not okay if i do that
because essentially what i'm doing is
that part of a's contribution is
exclusively used to meet other people's
accuracy and it's not at all helping
that person
this was something we defined this uh
sorry
yeah both of them are something we
defined the first one is called
individual rationality in more detail
what this is really saying is that
an allocation or procurement of
resources okay if first of all every
agent's accuracy constraint is going to
be met by it
okay which is up to now we've
taken this at the face value
and on top of that
and on top of that
if their accuracy could have been met by
something
that is um much smaller that is smaller
than what they would have needed to
learn by themselves
okay
so if that is met this is an
individually rational sort of learning
or at least procurement mechanism you
are never asked to provide more samples
that you would have needed to do to just
learn your own distribution
that's the first point
the second point which is that you don't
want your data to be exclusively used
for somebody else is very similar in the
sense that you still want the agent
accuracy constraint to be met
but what you don't want is that
you don't want an agent to be able to
reduce the number of samples by a little
bit
and
keep their accuracy being met but then
hurt somebody else okay so that would be
again a bad allocation because i'm asked
to provide something where part of
whatever i'm providing is exclusively
used for somebody else's benefits
how do i formalize that again
it should not be the case that i could
have met my learning guarantee with
something less
if everybody else kept their current
sort of
the amount of resources that they're
providing
and this is something we'll call stable
equilibria
given
the fact that i don't have time i'm
gonna skip more formal treatment of them
but is there
questions about what they were
essentially trying to say
so they refer to two natural concepts
individual rationality is an economics
concept that essentially says that by
joining a mechanism you're never doing
worse than not joining it and not
joining it is essentially like you do
something by yourself
and stable equilibria is an analogous
form of something like nash equilibria
which essentially says that nobody has
any incentive to sort of deviate
unilaterally from the current
scenario
okay so i'll
skip the formal treatment but i do want
to say that why they matter
they're obviously above welfare of the
agents because we're talking about
reason what is reasonable what's not
reasonable but they're also about
usability and stability of the systems
over time especially like if you think
about if people come to a mechanism at
first they don't know if the mechanism
is stable or not or if it's individually
rational or not and if they figure out
it's not then they'll drop out or
they'll reduce how much they're
providing and then that makes the whole
mechanism to work much worse for
everybody else as well
and again
just
continuing on the line of showing how
current algorithms current data sets do
really poorly with this
surprisingly poorly with this is that
take a standard learning algorithm
that's currently being used um on
federated over um
for federated learning
what you can see is that something like
60 of the agents can unilaterally reduce
their contributions to
five percent of their current rate so if
they were giving a hundred samples now
they they can just give five
but of course if they feel like they can
do this and they do deviate then the
learning mechanism can't learn anything
useful so it's not that the learning
mechanism was wasteful intentionally
it's just that it was really poorly
assigning these resources and first
trying to procure them in a really
unfair and unreasonable way
so now that we know they're important
do they first of all exist
and
how good are they
so in terms of existence um it's not
hard to think about an
rational allocation because all you need
to do is to make sure nobody's giving
more than they should have in the first
place
you can just kind of learn in a
non-collaborative way like individually
learn across tasks and you can do it so
definitely learning mechanisms exist
that are individually rational
unfortunately i cannot say the same
thing about stable equilibria
but in most cases they do exist
now
what is a bad case for an equilibrium
not existing
if every agent was so much better at
solving not just their own task but the
next guy
then we could get into these bad cyclic
behavior
so one example of this is to think about
each of these agents
they can solve both their own tasks well
and the next guy like whenever they
solve their own task whenever they take
a
single sample they've solved the next
guy's task too
so then what happens is that the first
person starts sampling solve their task
but they also solve this guy's task so
this guy doesn't need to sample at all
so they they're not going to sample
nobody helped this guy so this guy has a
sample
while he samples he solves this person's
task and now we go back and the first
person doesn't want to have sampled
so this is
not an equilibrium and no equilibria
sort of exists in this type of that's
cyclic behavior
this is very similar to why
um these cycling behaviors also happen
in games when you're thinking about
trying to get a pure nash equilibria and
these games are actually like what
you're trying to do it's very similar to
pure pure strategy equilibria and they
might not exist if you don't have
continuous functions and continuous
action spaces because you can get this
type of cycling behavior
i'm not going to go into too much more
detail other than the fact that saying
that
if i had continuity that's all i would
have needed
and some kind of monotonicity in the
sense that the minimum thing you really
need and it's sufficient is that if the
loss was monotone decreasing and
sampling effort the more you work the
better it was for you
and it was lip [ __ ] so it didn't like
it didn't drop too fast or it didn't
like get stuck for a while and then drop
okay
and since i don't have a lot of time i'm
not gonna give more intuition about this
just saying that if you can randomize a
little bit about how many samples you
take you can sort of address these
problems
the last thing here is really about okay
even if they did exist
are they okay are they so much worse
possibly than my optimal collaboration
you know i spent half of the tutorial
really focusing in the middle about how
to optimally learn
would these incentives cancel all the
efforts we did to a degree or not can we
understand them
they don't cancel all the effort but
they do provide a significant challenge
that we need to understand which is that
they might require collaborative
resources much more than optimal
collaboration would have required
and these bad equilibrium there are
these bad equilibria where some of the
agents shouldn't add all sample if you
want to be in an equilibria
unfortunately those are the agents whose
samples would have been super useful
what's one example of this at a high
level imagine you had a type of setting
where this person's data set was very
central was very generic
and then there were whole different
distributions populations that only
intersected with this generic thing in a
little like a tiny place
okay
so
the central agent
because their task is so generic if they
learned their own task really well they
essentially have given enough of an
information for every agent here so that
none of those agents need to sample
so in some way the optimal way to do
this type of sampling
if you didn't worry about incentives is
that the central agent should do all of
the work because they're just really
good at it
but because they're so good at it it's
the reason they're so good at is because
their task is so generic
that if these guys learning task was met
by default this person's learning tasks
would have also been met because it's
just too generic of a task
so in a stable or rational setting
they should take no work
they should just rely on everybody
else's employees
now when everybody else samples because
they're so different from each other we
need to sample a lot more
and ideas of this type can tell you that
there is quite a big gap between optimal
sample complexity
and one that is either rational or you
know or stable and that gap could be
square root of k
this doesn't completely say that we
completely ruined what we worked for the
first half because
it's
it actually doesn't this is about very
specific type of distributions the
distributions where the opt is just way
too small we don't know if for
reasonable ops um there is actually such
a misalignment between incentives and
optimality and i think that's a for
those of you interested i think it's
really good to sort of go beyond the
worst case here and try to understand
incentives in a much more reasonable
less uh boutique way
kind of the takeaway here that i want to
have is that
in some cases the equilibria are quite
structured
in a good way in a bad way you saw one
example where the structure of
equilibria said that you have to be an
efficient
but there are also settings that say
that the utility and the loss of the
agent um
sort of some people have to like
do no work essentially
and with that really this part what i
want you to take away is to think about
new mathematical foundation that we need
to propose we don't yet have a good
sense of it but we do need to propose
this
okay
and
i realized i even miscomputed the amount
of time that i had so i even kept you
here longer than i thought i was keeping
you here
so
really just to recap we asked some
fundamental questions that i'm not going
to repeat since i've kept you here for
way too long but if you are interested
in this line of work hopefully we can
spend some time in the semester to think
about how we should go about learning
from multiple distributions
thank you
sorry i thought i saw